[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to this week's episode
of the week in 60 minutes I'm your host
this week John Connolly The Spectators
news editor
coming up on the show
this week the bank of England made a 65
billion pound intervention as a pound of
ricocheted and the cost of government
borrowing sword I'll speak to Kate
Andrews Katie bulls and James Forsyth
about the political and economic Fallout
labor have achieved their largest ever
lead in a yugov poll I asked Sir John
Curtis about what that means for the
conservatives
Rupa Hook was suspended from the labor
party this week for suggesting that the
chancellor was superficially black I'll
speak to Ben a Beezy Jackie about race
and the left
Douglas Murray upset West Midlands
police with his spectator column last
week he tells me about the Fallout
and finally Kate summer scale has a new
book about phobias and manias I'll be
joined by the author
this episode is sponsored by kanakor
genuity wealth management experience
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times
visit can do wealth.com for more
information
and why not subscribe to our YouTube
channels as well click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
the markets have passed their verdicts
on Liz truss and quasi-clartang's mini
budget it isn't good pan fell to an
all-time low and the bank of England had
to intervene to prevent a run on Pension
funds where does this leave the piano
and will the economy recover
Spectators economics editor Kate Andrews
writes this week's cover piece about the
economic panic she joins me now
alongside James Forsyth and Katie balls
Katie James and Kate thank you for
joining us on spec TV now Kate it's been
a remarkable week since the mini budget
Last Friday come to start us off can you
take us through a bit of what's gone on
this week and what's been happening with
the markets
sure there's so much to cover let's just
start at the beginning and I suppose we
all probably have a tweet or a
prediction that we've sent out that we
slightly regret
um but in in terms of getting it so
wrong we can go back to a tweet sent out
by the new Chief secretary to the
treasury Chris felt right after
quasiquartang sat down from presenting
his mini budget and in that budget he
announced 45 billion pounds worth of tax
cuts at least 70 billion pounds worth of
additional borrowing paid no lip service
to fiscal discipline and Phil tweets out
great to see Sterling Rising on the back
of the UK growth plan uh he tweeted that
out because very very briefly we saw the
pound start to rise and then very
quickly we saw it fall and we saw it
fall further and further and we saw the
borrowing costs that the government
would have to pay start to rise then we
get to the weekend and the chancellor
decides to double down on his tax
cutting budget saying you basically you
know to pair phrases it's just the
beginning there's a lot more to come and
then by the time the markets are opening
in Asia over Sunday night into Monday
morning here in the UK as you can see
from this graph things are going even
worse the pound hits a all-time record
low of 103 at the time of recording this
it has slightly recovered to where it
was last Friday around 107 108 still low
historically for the pound a pretty weak
pound but those borrowing costs they
continue to Surge which you can see from
this graph here so by the time we get to
Monday and Tuesday uh it's very clear
that the markets are in panic eventually
there's an intervention from the
treasury and the bank of England not
what people were expecting they expected
the bank was going to have some kind of
emergency interest rate rise but instead
the bank issued a statement saying look
essentially more interest rate Rises
will be coming but we're not going to
move immediately the treasury promise
that its medium-term fiscal plan would
be announced at the end of November and
you know a lot of people are saying
that's very far away we need more
details now but they at least paid lip
service the idea that some kind of
acknowledgment about how much all this
is going to cost was coming now I should
note there is an international story to
be told as well as a domestic one it so
happens that quasi-core tank stood up
and presented this budget in the weeks
in which it became clear that something
was fundamentally changing in terms of
the economic era that we've been in of
cheap money and extremely low interest
rates across the world the cost to
borrow has been going up bond yields
which are the interest rate that
governments borrow at have been rising
for essentially all Western countries in
Germany and France they're at a 10-year
high as you can see from this graph but
of course what you'll also see on this
graph is that while countries are seeing
their borrowing costs going up since
this mini budget the uks have run away
and they have experienced to higher rise
than almost any other country so I think
you're getting a sense here that the
attention that the UK decided to draw to
itself made it an outlier and this is
not the time to be an outlier now by the
time we hit Wednesday the bank of
England is announcing quite a serious
intervention their decision just last
week to start quantitative tightening
and to start selling off some of that
debt that it had bought during the Copa
crisis is reversed a complete U-turn and
the bank announces that it's actually
going to start printing more money and
buying more debt and this was
essentially to stop quite a dangerous
run on pensions that could have seen
some Pension funds go bust so a
temporary measure but really quite a
notable one all of this is meant to give
the government a little bit more time to
come up with what its strategy is what
it's going to announce next and how it's
going to signal to markets that it is
aware that it needs to be responsible
and to get markets calmer and more under
control but at the moment we don't see
indication of any kind of speeding up
from Downing Street to make those
announcements Liz truss has been doing a
regional media tour and a local media
tour talking about her plan and I think
trying to sell it a bit more to explain
to people what she's thinking why
borrowing in the short term she believes
will lead to a lower tax and higher
growth economy which she hopes will pay
for itself but at the moment there's no
signs of backing down there's no signs
of a U-turn from a government we
continue to watch the markets closely
and John I suspect we're going to see
more surprises along the way
and on that James do you think so as
Kate says that the bank of England had
to step in do you think that's calmed
things down with regards to pensions for
example I know there was a lot of worry
that you've you've mentioned before that
um they could have some very bad things
going on with our Pension funds do you
think that's been sort of held off now
yes until October the 14th because this
is this Bank of England intervention is
Unlimited in terms of quantity but it is
time limited it stops on October the
14th and I mean there is a clear reason
for that when you talk to people in the
city familiar with the banks thinking
which is the bank is saying Parliament
Returns on October the 11th and we are
essentially giving the government until
October the 14th to have uh regained the
confidence of the market so that you
don't see these spiking borrowing costs
at the moment the government doesn't
intend to sell out its fiscal rules
until November the 23rd I think the
question is you know can that hold are
they going to have to move that forward
I'm not sure it is sustainable given
what has happened in the markets to say
you'll have to wait six weeks to find
out what our plan is
hmm and Casey what do you think the
reaction to this is inside number 10
what sort of sentence do you get what
they're thinking they can't be entirely
calm now about all this
I think it's been a really interesting
one because initially and I think
particularly on Friday it felt pretty
studs up in terms of the attitude and I
think that uh the chance the the Prime
Minister uh you know the Inner Circle
openly felt that they were doing
something quite bold the markets uh you
know might think what they think but
they would get on board and actually
just hold your nerve and I think as Kate
just so accidentally laid out the events
that have happened since then I think
you now got quite a lot of shaky
ministers members of the cabinet saying
wait did you really account for you know
the fact that mortgage offers are being
redrawn the fact that uh ultimately the
market is betting on a huge a spike in
interest rates which means lots of pain
for those who need to renew their
mortgage those who are on track and
mortgages and obviously MPS are starting
to panic because they're getting lots of
worried calls from constituents who are
saying am I going to be going to be able
to keep up with my mortgage payments
what does this mean for me
um and that I think gets to a point
where even though I think we see in the
fact that Downing Street uh almost is
quite separate and some of this they're
talking to one another and I think have
probably taken a bit longer to really
get a sense of the concern I think in
The Wider party and Country I think
there is now perhaps a belated
acceptance
um that this budget has has not gone to
Japan that it has had undesirable
effects and what do you now do at this
point I think there's still a sense that
the best thing to do is to push on and
actually and to change and to tactic
would be to lose political Capital but I
think Liz truss and quasi guardang are
now in a while there are no good options
really in terms of how you respond to
this because you can try and see it out
you can hold your nerve but the markets
are obviously looking for a change
um and the other option is something I
think some ministers and MPS would like
to see which is a change of tech now Liz
trust did say that she was going to
borrow to fund tax cuts but I think
where there is anger I'm picking up on
amongst ministers is she talked about
the National Insurance at reversal and
shortbread corporation tax what she
announced on Friday what causes
announced on Friday went above and
beyond there and therefore there's a
problem in the sense I had one former
cabinet minister say to me
the politics are awful and the economics
don't look good either so they
effectively feel they're in a double
loss period and therefore what is the
least worst option for Liz trust some
people have been saying or some MPS she
needs to remove her chance the
quasi-quarter and he does not have the
confidence of the markets I think that
is something to be incredibly reluctant
to do I also don't think it would really
fix the problem given this is Liz
trust's economic strategy and it's
really hard to say oh it's all because
of this person over here who I helped
plan the whole thing out with and also
it's not clear that she wants to
massively change Tech and then I think
one thing I think we're going to see MPS
calling more for is to at the very least
delay this idea of abolishing the 45p
rate for the highest earners and I think
that would clearly suggest that Liz
trust was u-turning and so we say oh
this lady is for turning she does not
actually have you know these Steely
nerves but it is I think where lots of
MPS are now feeling as
if you need to send something you might
not get the markets back on side or
regain full confidence but I think
looking ahead to the fact that uh
quasiquitang and Liz trust are going to
have to send some signals and that could
be spending cuts and so how politically
sustainable is it to at a time when
you're saying no to some of these pay
Rises where tightening of belts
um mortgage rates going up to really
have this tax cut for the highest
earners and I think there's just one to
watch notably in the regional interview
round Liz trusted this morning she
didn't massively defend that she was
trying to talk instead about energy
support and so while I don't think it's
where number 10 are right now I wonder
if that's perhaps one of the landing
zones so that might be where we're going
on the political side getting rid of the
45p top raid
um okay Katie mentioned there that might
not restore confidence when it comes to
the markets I mean what candlest trust
do now to do that or is or have they've
just been completely spooked by her
Premiership already
well they've definitely been spook but
there are certainly things she could do
to to calm the the market Jitters I
think Katie's laid out really well why
that's going to be so politically
difficult the obvious one is when
quasi-portang announces his medium-term
fiscal plan he could get things back on
track by announcing talking about
essentially the other side of the
Leisure which is the spending side and
there are options that are already being
floated in the press and speculated
about perhaps they won't give an
inflation raise to departmental budgets
for example if they were to freeze uh
spending where it is now that would be
in real term certainly a spending cut
quite substantial one but then you have
to ask yourself is this government
really prepared going into this winter
as People's Energy bills are rising as
the NHS is quite clearly on its knees
are they ready to say real-term spending
cut for Health Care real-time spending
cut for Education real-term spending cut
for criminal justice in which the
backlog is atrocious real-time spending
cut for defense which Liz truss has
promised to actually increase defense
spending quite significantly in the
coming years that's going to be
politically very difficult and as Katie
pointed out with that 45p tax rate gone
it's very hard to say well look you know
we're going to cut over here when
actually we gave this tax cut now in
terms of the numbers I think you can
make the argument there that the 45p
rate actually compared to everything
else she decided to cut in terms of
taxes last week is is very tiny amount
it's about 2 billion pounds worth of the
45 billion pounds of tax cuts so you
know it isn't the case that perhaps
cutting that top rate means that other
things can't be funded but that of
course will be the narrative and it's
going to be quite convincing political
narrative so I think that puts them in
in a really tough position I suppose
they could roll back on some of the
things that they've announced that would
be another way to to make up for the the
holes in the public finances that they
have grown to say actually okay we will
make maybe we won't completely roll back
but we'll change the timelines and that
tax cut won't come in in April it'll
come in in 2024 or something along those
lines
um very difficult again though to see
how a new prime minister who has a
mandate from her Grassroots essentially
to do what she's done you turns on the
first big statement that her Chancellor
made I mean it that would that would
suggest that the Premiership
um is already very much on the rocks and
I don't think that's the message that
the government will want to send so it's
not as if we're in some kind of space
that we can't come back from it isn't as
if we've actually fallen over the cliff
yet the the graphs and the indication in
the markets is is not there yet but they
would have to make some pretty bold
updates and announcements to get things
under control and the politics of that
is going to be really tricky and James
if we're looking at sort of political
difficulties had economic ones um seems
like there's a huge public concern about
mortgage is going up
um do you think it's sort of inevitable
now that rates are going to go up and
and what kind of impact is that going to
have
I think rates were going to go up to
some extent anyway I think well the
problem with the government have done is
they meant these increase in interest
rates are going to be sharper than they
would have been previously because as
you pill the chief Economist of Banker
England says one of the things that
requires a significant monetary policy
response is this loosening of fiscal
policy uh to the extent that the trust
government did last week and so interest
rates are going to spike and that is a
real problem for the Tory party because
look at the last election uh Victoria's
trailed by double digits among people
who rented their homes in both the
private renter sector and the social
rented sector among people the mortgage
they had a 10-point lead and they are
just about as one veteran talk about
Manchester me said they've just put a
massive tax on their base because they
have driven interest rates up higher
than they otherwise would have been and
I mean this is the real flaw here which
is you know lots of the attention is
focused on on the value of sterling and
how Sterling has fallen to a touch
record lows against the dollar uh but I
actually think in terms of of of of the
viability of a trust plan the two
biggest issues are that the cost of
government borrowing has risen so much
right and if you go back and read Kate's
absolutely excellent primer on trust
economics the whole whole thing is
predicated on the idea that the markets
would be happy to fund at low rate this
inverted Commons transition to a low tax
economy that idea is not working out
right now to put it mildly and then the
second issue is you know as interest
rates rise that hits uh people with
mortgages it's ultimately going to hit
people who rent to as landlords pass
that cost on and that is going to
depress economic activity because people
are going to have less discretionary
money to spend and so although they have
cut taxes in this budget including
personal taxes very few people are going
to feel better off and go out and spend
more money and so at the moment this
whole budget was meant to be about going
for growth I I am struggling to see
where the growth comes from and that two
and a half percent a growth Target now
looks very ambitious and Casey and trust
is going to have a few problems on the
home front as well I imagine I mean her
back bench MPS can't be happy at the
moment and she's presumably going to get
some legislation through the Commons at
some point I mean how big a problem do
you think that will be for her
I think it's a big problem that
ultimately Tori MPS are very unhappy
right now and
to be fair you look at past years it's
not a particularly new thing Tori MP is
being unhappy and but I think it is
surprising how quickly uh this this has
come to her head I think ultimately Liz
truss made the decision to Chuck so much
in the mix on Friday because uh she and
her team were aware that ultimately over
time political Capital dwindles it tends
to go down not up and so why not at your
moment in maximum strength try and push
as many things through as you can
um but obviously the byproduct or the
result of that so to speak is the fact
that her political Capital has fallen
because the markets have reacted so
badly that is in turn of speaking MPS
because constituents are worried and one
of the things and Liz trust condition
reassure the markets is not just
obviously pointed into where there will
be some spending restraint which isn't
really going to be a massive vote winner
for being honest at least in the short
term but they can also talk about the
supply side reform now there were hints
of this on Friday and But ultimately
supply side reform so it is tricky it
tends to be unpopular and it requires
lots of votes in the House of Commons so
you need to get a your cabinet on the
side to really front some potentially
unpopular measures and you whether
that's planning also we know Liz truss
for example on immigration wants to
relax uh the cap for social occupations
so you need to get uh your cabinet to
front these things and then you also
need to get on some of the aspects of
this so relaxing of regulations and so
forth MPS to vote this through and we
already saw how disruptive um and how
tricky it was for Boris Johnson but even
with a majority of 80 that he won in the
region of 80 and he and he won that so I
think it does literally and that's why
actually you get back to the sense
amongst MPS and I think Julian Smith the
former Chief Whitman public yesterday
saying the government can have a growth
plan but it's going to need changes and
that's when you get to the obviously as
trust has an economic problem but she
also has a political problem and I think
that's why
right now it's quite hard to see without
a big change in terms of the markets are
responding which could reassure MPS how
she doesn't have to do something to
signal to MPS and you know give them
something if she is going to have to
then uh get the help to push all these
various reforms through and finally
before we go okay
um we also had quite an unusual reaction
to the mini budget this week from the
IMF
um can you tell us a bit about that and
why why that intervention was so strange
well the international monetary fund
ended up releasing a statement albeit I
think in response to journalists asking
them about what they thought was going
on in the UK and the State win was
essentially a telling off a suggestion
that the UK probably shouldn't be
increasing borrowing at this time
um as you can see from our inflation
graph and I'm sure as our viewers are
well aware of uh inflation is close to
10 in the UK and the IMF suggested that
some of these tax cuts could be
inflationary
um but actually the the biggest telling
off and I think the strangest part of
the reaction was that it was making
direct comment on the decision to cut
taxes for high earners and how perhaps
there was an ethical issue with that
decision looking more at how they
perceive the ethics rather than how they
perceive the economics now this is a
gift to trust's critics because they can
say the IMF has intervened and you know
in normal times that would be a huge
statement but in this case it really was
a telling off
um it is also however ammo for those who
are trusted supporters because this is
exactly the kind of thing that they mean
when they talk about the Orthodoxy the
treasury Orthodoxy the economic
Orthodoxy that they want to take a ham
or two
um the IMF frankly does have a very
political history of focusing on
inequality specifically feeling that
um reduction inequality is a good thing
in and of itself that's something that
trust in quartet reject they reject that
premise and that was very clear in the
mini budget speech when quarteng said
this is the end of redistribution
politics we're now going for growth
their focus is on growing the size of
the pie rather than the actual
inequality between say different income
earners and so you saw list trust
supporters like David Frost pick up on
that statement and say you know this is
exactly what we expected to have happen
um you know these are the kinds of
attacks that justify what Liz truss is
doing so there was basically something
for everyone in that IMF statement uh
and I think it is a reminder sure that
Wells it has obviously obviously been a
very tricky week for tressanomics and
the first time it's been tested you know
it's come up against a lot of hurdles
and I suspect that there will be more
but it's also a reminder that there are
a lot of people out there who do feel
like there's an Orthodoxy that needs to
come to an end who still are insistent
that she's doing the right thing and
won't hurt to hold her nerve and they
think they hope that the markets will
calm down that a bit more reassurance
from the treasury will help things along
and that ultimately even if the response
hasn't been great the individual
policies that she announced are decent
ones and I think you're going to
continue to see that debate play out
whilst this has been an explosive week
in in terms of the markets it certainly
has not ended the debate I think between
uh the the trust economic supporters and
those who are far more skeptical
brilliant thank you Kate thank you Casey
and thank you James
if you enjoy spectator TV then why not
subscribe to the magazine go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
to try one month of the magazine in
print and online for free
labor searched for a 17-point lead of
the Tories in a recent poll their
largest ever in a ugov survey pulling
experts to John Curtis joins me now
then John thank you for joining us on
spectator TV
um we've seen this week uh Labor's
biggest poll lead yet over the Tories in
a I think it's a Hugo poll
um how bad is it looking for the Tories
would you say in your view
well it's looking pretty bad
um we've now had four opinion polls
conducted
since last Friday's fiscal statement or
mostly conducted since Friday's fiscal
statement
um on they vary in the extent to which
they suggest there's been a swing away
from the conservatives towards labor
but on average they now put labor 15
points ahead
and checking back through the records
this morning I think uh this is the
highest sustained lead that labor have
enjoyed in the polls since David Cameron
first entered Downing Street back in
2010. there were some pretty substantial
labor leads in 2012 2013 but not quite
on this scale now in part that is a
reaction to last Friday's fiscal event
before last Friday's fiscal event uh the
conservatives were only I say only nine
points behind in the polls the figures
now
increased to 15. but the fact that the
conservatives were nine points behind
last Friday is an indication of the
other problem that the conservatives
have now and the other problem that
underlies the position of the polls
which is that basically the accession of
Liz Truss
to the party leadership produced very
very little in the way of a balance the
labor lead narrowed by a point between
the end of August and uh before last
Friday now of course she wasn't helped
by the fact
that the period of national mourning
didn't give her much chance to impress
herself on the public
but of course the problems you now face
is is that now that she has had an
opportunity to do so the immediate
reaction has been negative not only in
terms of the party's General numbers but
also her personal numbers now a lot of
people sort of make up a mind about it
but Redfield and Wilton when they polled
on Monday having polled the previous
Thursday uh recorded an eight-point
increase in the proportion of people who
said they disapproved of her performance
um and it's pretty clear that the budget
itself so-called non-budget went down
pretty badly
um a few indications for example from
yougov
um they find around three times as many
people thinking that the budget was
unfair than fair
it was at least Brave of the
conservatives to produce a budget that
you know pretty clearly by all uh
economic analysis was one that gave more
to those who are better off than those
who are less well-off at a time when
British social attitudes which had been
released the previous day had indicated
that we are as a society now somewhat
more concerned about inequality than was
the case uh before the pandemic so
that's not the direction in which the
public mood has been going
um but also 60 of people saying that yes
well you know yeah we quite like the tax
cuts but frankly we don't think they are
affordable nearly a half of people
thinking that the event was risky and
then more recently find out now again
finding around twice as many people just
saying we think this was a bad fiscal
statement than a good one so it's pretty
clear that the statement itself has gone
down pretty badly I think the the issue
it's now up for grabs but which parts
might concern the conservatives most is
to what extent has the reaction of the
last few days
a undermined the electorates
um confidence in the government's
economic competence
and has it created an event an
impression a memory of a crisis over
which they felt the government didn't
have have control
um now the reason why the latter matters
is that if you basically go through the
history of governments that presided
over a sterling crisis a fiscal crisis
stroke of financial crisis such as labor
in the late 1940s 1976 1992
2008 and nine those governments
basically did not survive at The Ballot
Box uh to the next election even if as
in the case of John Major's government
uh the um Sterling crisis was followed
by substantial economic growth of the
kind that perhaps the current
conservative government would love to
have the problem was that people lost
their confidence in the government's
ability to run the economy uh it was a
event that became impressioned on their
political memories and as a result the
basically it was very very difficult for
the government to recover now we don't
yet really know whether or not what this
event is in that League or not think we
will need more polling to see where we
end up and to see how people have
reacted to the events of the last two or
three days but the one thing one can say
it doesn't prove the analogy but it
certainly demonstrates the potential of
the analogy if it's there is if you look
at the reverse that the conservatives
have suffered in the polls vis-a-vis
Labor uh since last Friday six points as
I've already mentioned that's not far
short of the immediate impact of the ERM
crisis of 1992. so if the public memory
uh is one of a government that's not in
control then you can see that this
government is already perhaps suffering
some of the Electoral consequences that
have flown afflowed from previous crises
so indeed this is a crisis so John to
give us a bit of sense of context if the
says the number of stairs they are now
for trust has any sort of government in
power ever recovered from these kind of
numbers is it all over basically
well if it's all over it will be because
well it will be of two things one is
because of this begets this gets
imprinted on uh the voters uh memory one
and two we do have to remember that the
fundamental problem the conservatives
face is they don't have any friends
inside the House of Commons so basically
you know nobody doesn't have to win the
next election the conservatives simply
have to lose it once they're below about
320 seats that's it there is no way the
conservatives will be able to sustain an
Administration for that the
conservatives will need to be ahead in
the opinion polls now
the potential uh Silver Lining is many
uh commentators pointed out is that the
polls show a lot of 2019 conservative
voters not saying they're going to vote
labor but saying they don't know
on the one hand that's what happens when
parties become unpopular if you look at
what happened to Liberal Democrats in
the 2013 to 2015 Parliament that severe
drop in their support during that
Parliament was accompanied by a lot of
don't knows then the party comforted
itself with the thought that you know
they'll come back to us in 2015 well
they didn't so the Tories can't Bank on
it but at least perhaps there's some
possibility of them recovering but the
truth is that probably now would not be
enough but sure there's nothing in there
I mean the only thing one can also say
that as compared with the kind of leads
that uh Tony Blair enjoyed over uh John
Major uh certainly by 1995 you're you're
talking about the labor party typically
being around you know a 50 and plus the
conservatives well below 30 the concerns
are not in the balance position as that
and it's also perfectly clear that
although uh that that you know maybe
secure Style is now being regarded by
voters as a potential prime minister but
he's nothing like as popular as as
um as uh Tony Blair was two years up
from an election I mean Tony Blair had
twice as many people uh saying they were
satisfied with him more than
dissatisfied on ipsis Morris measure
um uh secure stone is still in quite a
lot of negative territory so um I don't
think one can say yet it's all over but
I think one has to say that this
government faces now a very substantial
electoral challenge
um the full scale of which will become
clear in the next few weeks but as I say
if indeed the electorate uh react
adversely not simply to last Friday's
event we already know they've done that
but also have their confidence further
undermined by the events of the last few
days then that difficulty will certainly
seem to be very substantial indeed
brilliant thank you very much John
yeah that's all in the labor party are
perhaps ready for government Rupa hook
who started this week as a labor MP has
made headlines for a rather than sendary
comments about the chancellor quasiqua
Tang here's what she said
but again he's got more in common if you
look at the beginning of stuff Joe Cox
if you look at the current emails to
Eaton I think he went to a very
expensive prep school all the way
through the top schools in the country
if you hear him on the Today program you
wouldn't know
so what was she thinking van obesity
Jack T joins me now to discuss
Ben thank you for joining us on
spectator TV what was your reaction what
did you think when you first heard those
comments from Rupa hook
sadly the the comments themselves
weren't that much of a surprise
um I think we've we've seen over the
sort of past few years uh a number of
Labor MPS have expressed similar
comments I think it's a widely held
belief amongst parts of the left
um that the people who are who are black
um shouldn't be conservatives
um and that therefore
um by being a conservative you are
somehow not not properly black so to
hear the comments and to hear him
described as being superficially black
was uh was very much on brand for a
certain part of the the labor party and
am I right in saying as well that you've
sort of faced similar comments in the
past as a as a Conservative candidate
and as being a conservative
um yeah it's it's funny it's it's a it's
a type of abuse that prior to being
involved in politics I'd never really
experienced myself
um it wasn't until I was a candidate in
the last election uh that I sort of
started to get a sort of a a sense that
this was a feeling that was more widely
held
um and survived a candidate in Hackney
North and Stoke Newington
um and I found that that I got a lot of
grief from Mostly from the black
community for being a black conservative
um I was very much the the wrong type of
black uh and it was it was very
disconcerting to be honest it really put
me on the back foot and and I sort of
bottom of a Twitter pile on of that kind
of abuse
um really makes you sort of stop and
think and wonder what it is initially
that you've done wrong and it's only
when you sit down and think about the
facts so that you haven't really done
anything wrong you're just being true to
who you are
um that you realize what a sort of
bizarre type of abuse it is to suffer um
and so it's something that isn't really
widely known and it isn't really widely
experienced and it's you know I thank
Rupa hook for for bringing it to
everyone's attention but this is
something that that is definitely a
problem and it's definitely a problem
that's getting worse because I've
noticed that
the sort of the validation of those
views is becoming more and more
commonplace more and more people feel
emboldened to say those things and given
that they seem to be able to say so with
impunity
um it simply exacerbates the problem
well I'm sorry to hear that sounds
deeply unpleasant
um why do you think it is do you think
it's why do you think it is so sort of
prevalent on on the left and and in the
labor party where do you think it comes
from this
um
it's difficult to say precisely I think
there's a real belief that
um amongst that group that the
conservative party is racist and
therefore anybody who aligns themselves
to the conservative party is either a
racist themselves or sympathetic uh to
those beliefs and therefore as somebody
of of color be it black be it Asian
um you are seen as being a traitor a
race traitor if you like um somebody who
is
um and these are the comments that I
receive sort of an Uncle Tom or somebody
who is a sellout someone who is being
seen to be working against the interests
of the black community
um and that would be fine if if politics
was simply a one issue
one issue uh event where everything was
focused on Race but race is such a tiny
tiny piece of the overall puzzle
um that it seems incredible that that
there are those who obsess about this to
the extent that it it sort of colors
every judgment that they're willing to
make of anybody in the political
ideology that they subscribe to and Rupa
hook has been suspended we should say by
the late party after making these
comments and she's offered an apology
though not immediately
um do you get the feeling though that
lay party needs to do more about this
that it's just kind of doing that is not
quite enough maybe
I think it's I think it's interesting um
the late party was was really credited
for for their Swift response uh to the
to the comments
um but at the same time only after the
audio had leaked and the chairman of the
conservative party had written a letter
demanding for her suspension
um and I think the labor party very much
took the view that
um sort of discretion was a better part
of valor and actually to throw Rupa hook
under the bus
um was going to be uh the the easiest
option um particularly given that it
clashed with obviously stormers uh storm
of speech and they didn't want to take
any of the Shine off that so I do have
limited sympathy
um for their for their plight but I
think the interesting part is that in
Rupert's apology you know the classic
140 character tweets saying that her
comments were real judged she never
explained why she said them and she
never explained what she really meant by
them and no one's really asked her what
that apology means in context do you no
longer believe that he's superficially
black
do you have an issue with sort of black
people in the conservative party more
widely I think these are the questions
that that Rupert probably needs to
answer and if she's ever to hope to get
the whip back and for labor to be able
to give her the whip back with any
credibility she's going to have to show
that
why she said those things and and sort
of justify any change of opinion that
she's had and I think that's where the
work really needs to be done we've seen
there are countless other examples of
other labor MPS saying very similar
things Dawn Butler quoted Dr Shola moo
in the chamber by referring to people's
racial Gatekeepers we saw Clive Lewis
tweet James cleverley and and say that
he was embarrassed for the fact that
he'd had to to go on the news and defend
a position or paraphrasing but uh but
effectively asked him where his
credibility was and so I think these are
these are issues that clearly sit
amongst those uh labor MPS who are very
much on the the far left of the party do
you feel I mean so the conservatives
have a particularly diverse cabinet at
the moment it's got sort of great MPS
coming through from a variety of
backgrounds do you feel like maybe the
tour pass has got a bit of a healthier
attitude to race than labor
um I think that's that's very much the
case I think the difference between the
labor party and the conservative party
is that
the labor party very much takes its
ethnic minority votes for granted
um it expects people from ethnic
minorities to vote for them I think
that's where some of their their
Prejudice comes towards people who are
on the the rights who have conservative
views
um I think the conservative party trusts
that people will subscribe to that
ideology because it's what they believe
in not because of some
personal defining characteristics be
there that be they that they are
gender sexuality race
um I think it's very much the case that
if you subscribe to this ideology then
you are welcome to join and you're
welcome to be part of this
um I don't think it's the case that the
people are expected to vote conservative
simply because of a certain sort of
upbringing that they had or or their um
sort of the the background that they've
they've grown up with and I think in
that respect there is very much a a
healthier attitude
brilliant thank you very much ben
now our columnist Douglas Murray can
count many influential people among his
readership certainly they might not all
agree with him one reaction to his
column last week was particularly
remarkable it's a rather extraordinary
story so we've asked Douglas to join us
on the show
so
Douglas we're gonna be talking about
your column this week
um but that kind of It kind of follows
on from your column last week so can you
tell us a bit about that for anyone who
dared to missed it of course if anyone
missed it um I wrote last week about the
events that have been going on in
Leicester uh in recent weeks really
since the end of last month when there's
been Community tensions between the
Hindu community and the Muslim Community
as a result really we're started it
seems because of a cricket match at the
end of August
um and things got really nasty there and
I talked among other things about the
fact that here were two groups of you
know young men a lot of them seem to be
or at least some of them seem to be
carrying some form of arms and uh things
are getting very ropey and the local
police were there as a thin yellow line
I mentioned in passing that there were
several women there with sticks and it
didn't seem to be entirely adequate
necessarily for two very very you know
gung-ho groups of young men and I
mentioned in passing that of course I
don't know if there was a much trans
representation or indeed were there any
gays at the event because um they
weren't whether or not and whether or
not they were dancing the Macarena which
is what we now expect of course of
lgbtqi plus offices as we know so I
mentioned that in passing as a real dig
just at the fact that for years the
British police have put diversity they
advertise diversity as the main thing
they don't really bother if you get your
bike stolen they don't really bother if
you get your house robbed they don't
even look of CCTV but they love to paint
their cars rainbow they love to have
photographed high heels and much more
and so I think that uh you know one of
my basic rules is that if you make
yourself ridiculous you should expect to
be ridiculed you shouldn't make yourself
ridiculous and then when somebody
ridicules you say how dare you what
would make you do that so you're writing
about a serious issue yeah sectarian
violence breaking out in the streets of
Midlands people getting hurt there's
widespread violence you get a response
to your erps from the police yeah what
does what does that say yeah and that's
what you're writing about this week and
literally what the comment I just made
was that there was a throwaway comment
humorous if I may say so myself
and the police turned out to be enraged
by it uh the um I I read actually since
I got in front of me uh what the chief
Constable of West Midlands police wrote
he he wrote a letter to our editor
my boss he dobbed me in and he said
among other things he said if Mr Murray
were to rise from his comfortable chair
and toddle up to the West Midlands he
would find plenty of women and LGBT
officers more than capable of putting
him on his backside if he came at them
waving his sharp fountain pen now that's
the David Thompson who's the chief
Constable of West Midlands police uh he
he went on to say that that his his men
and men women and these I assume know
very well how to deal with the thugs
they confront keeping the king's piece
so it's interesting he called the Muslim
gangs thugs
um but anyway and then then others
joined in Louisa Rolfe and assistant
commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
here in London added that she said to me
we have room in a carrier for you so so
a chief Constable promised that he could
he his officers could throw could put me
onto my backside I.E beat me up and then
his colleague at uh the Metropolitan
Police promised they've got a police van
for me this is this is for making a dig
at the stupidity of the British police's
behavior in recent years on these issues
and I think it is so telling for a
number of reasons one is it's a great
reminder of the fact that the that the
British police have gone mad and this is
12 years into a conservative government
and there's no excuse for it people at
the top of the police like the chief
Council of West Britain's police sir
David Thompson not only to get knighted
but they get they get they get wafted
all the way up by doing this sort of
thing they're all political actors of
these they're not really interested in
policing they're interested in saying
the right things to get themselves
advanced in the police force so that
that's the first thing the second thing
is West Midlands police has a shocking
reputation as its own it's well known a
problem police force and I'm glad to
David Thompson has reminded us all of
that about about uh 12 years ago uh when
Channel 4 revealed that there were there
were uh preachers in in the West
Midlands area preaching Jihad and they
did this they put Channel 4 showed us in
a documentary who did the West Midlands
police and Sir David Thompson's
colleagues go for they didn't go for the
preacher they didn't go for the jihadis
they didn't go for the people who were
threatening the lives of other British
citizens no they decided to go for
channel four so so this is this is
actually just another example of the
fact that British police is in deep
disarray I think I think people like sir
David Thompson and Louisa Rolfe should
be absolutely ashamed of themselves I
don't consider this a threat I'm a big
enough boy to be able to take it but I
don't really expect Chief constables and
assistant Commissioners and Metropolitan
Police to be threatening journalists I
mean you mentioned your piece
um about the fact you know the police
have been doing the Macarena The Pride
festivals they seem to be they've taken
the knee in London yeah there seems to
be sort of a clear political agenda of
the police do you think it's kind of
linked on us it's almost about being
seen as righteous online and that's why
they're sort of coming for you well of
course I mean it was it's been like this
ever since the MacPherson report they've
just overcompensated on everything
um and and you know we see this on a
daily basis I mean the the the the way
they behave about Pride now is
absolutely sickling but as I say in the
piece it makes me start to feel really
quite homophobic I have to say I mean I
mean seriously getting your offices mail
offices to wear high heels and go sort
of ooh as if as a woman I'm a woman
maybe I'm a they maybe I'm a non-binary
it's like no stop people's houses
getting burgled like lock up rapists and
murderers and they've got really
terrible racist if you look at some of
these police forces like the West
Midlands please if you look at actual
rates of catching people for what they
regard as minor crimes it's absolutely
appalling they don't bother chasing up
this stuff oh oh but they love doing the
Macarena Manchester Pride to show how on
board with the gays they are I don't
give a damn about that stuff I'd be very
surprised if most British citizens give
a damn about that stuff what we do give
a damn about is our police officers
becoming political and political and
Incredibly ugly left-wing agenda
Direction and I said we mentioned as
well there's been another incident with
the police this week where Sussex police
uh they'd well pedophile had been
convicted essentially for abusing a
large number of people they now identify
as a woman and he identifies as a woman
he evangelizes a woman quite
um and he raped the kids when he was a
man when he was a man and throughout the
court case he's referred to as a man
actually because that's when his actions
took place like that and someone had the
temerity to sort of describe this person
as as a man and they were ticked off
online by Sussex police I mean what do
you make is coming from it's another
it's an even more obscene example of
what I just described where you know you
do the Macarena but you don't bother
with burglaries to to police pronouns
and and put the priority of a sex
offender pedophile rapists pronoun
preferences over an accurate description
of the crime and for the police to think
that's their role it's so sickening like
what does it matter whether you
misgender the person it you're not
misgendering anyway all that's happened
on this occasion is a male pedophile
rapist has been convicted and has since
tried to dress up and approximate the
look of a woman that's it West Midlands
police or any other police force Sussex
police they can have all sorts of views
about what pronouns doesn't matter a
damn the only thing that matters is that
that man is convicted if he's guilty and
he's sentenced to prison and he spends
the rest of his life in prison that
would be a good outcome why are Sussex
police policing
um pronouns for the same reason that the
police in this this country that still
tries to be serious on occasion that
this this formerly serious country has
police officers turning up at people's
doors telling them them that their
thoughts are wrong or that they're that
they've tweeted something online that
could cause somebody else distress we've
got a new Home Secretary Sarah bravaman
she thank goodness responded actually
very swiftly to the latest stupidity
from Sussex police
here's a challenge to swella Bravo if
she's watching you may you may well be
the last conservative Home Secretary for
some decades at the at the rate at which
the conservatives have been failing over
the last 12 years you may be the last
Home Secretary from the conservative
party for a very long time
so one way to avoid that fate would be
to get on top of this crap and get on
top of it fast get people like sir David
Thompson out of the force fire assistant
commissioner Louisa Rolf tell them that
it's not their job to please what
journalists say tell them that it's not
their job to tell people what pronouns
they should or should not use fire
people who can't catch criminals basic
crime can't police it can't do any of
that job get rid of them
there's a job brilliant thank you very
much Douglas
and finally are you scared of spiders or
public speaking perhaps you're one of
the many people afraid of buttons or
palindromes in the latest book Kate's
summer scale looks at the history of
phobias and the strange fears people
have got to in the past her book has
been reviewed in this week's issue by
Maggie Ferguson Kate joins the show
Kate thank you for joining us on
spectator TV now your book is out next
week
um the book of phobias and manias 99
obsessions that change the world
um what decide what made you decide to
write about phobias start us off and I
think I'm always interested in Peculiar
fixations and obsessions in sort of
ordinary people things that Verge on
Madness and phobias and manias are just
just that little pockets of strangeness
that we carry around with us and
fixations and I was very curious to know
especially when they were first
identified or invented and to trace the
history and it would be a way of sort of
understanding the history of Psychiatry
psychology but also just unearthing case
studies of people who had developed
these fixations so you mentioned you've
got all these phobias we've got things
like orniphobia to osmophobia and did
you have any particular favorites that
you enjoyed coming across or perhaps
were surprised to see yeah lots were
very surprising and intriguing I
especially like the ones that were
mysterious like
um
kumponophobia which is a phobia of
buttons which is
um surprisingly common I found by just
discussing it with people they'll often
say oh my mother's got that oh my I
um and Steve Jobs had it which was why
he wore his
polinex sweaters and chose not to wear
clothes yeah
well that is there is a theory that
should influenced the design of um his
devices because he liked everything to
be smooth and not buttery
no protrusions and that is an intriguing
one because it seems to be related to
the disgust reflex
um people who are horrified by buttons
are sort of disgusted by the kind of
recoil very often and it's not obvious
why there are lots of things we're
disgusted by which there is a sort of
clear evolutionary reason for it because
we recall from things that might
infect us or we associate with disease
but buttons not obviously so and so that
that was very sort of interesting to
pursue so so do you think that's do you
think all phobias come from the same
place or do you think some come from
maybe like childhood trauma and that
kind of thing or or are they all
evolutionary and that kind of thing well
quite often you can trace the back to
some kind of evolutionary protective
mechanism so we're scared of heights for
good reason
um and of water similarly and snakes
they can poison us
um but the survival of those fears or
their their ex the extreme versions of
them in certain people today
um is is not logical or rational by
definition a phobia is irrational but it
might often be based on a a once long
ago rational fear that protected us as a
species but the the trick the way that
they get awakened in US does seem often
to be associated with personal
experiences like a traumatic experience
a shock and that they can also be
learned they can be triggered by seeing
them in other people around us or by
watching a film that awakens the fear
and and establishes it so like all these
psychological things it's a mixture of
what's latent in us and what's aroused
by our society and our culture right
isn't it your book is a history so is
there a particular a time when you start
to see phobias emerge or as they have
they sort of been around forever and
that kind of thing well I think they've
been around forever but they were only
named as phobias and identified in the
late 18th century Benjamin Rush one of
the founding fathers of the United
States was the first to really treat
them as psychological conditions albeit
in a slightly humorous way and after
that the psychiatrist of the 19th
century had a field day naming
individual phobias and manias and
classifying and locating all these
quirks in people and so yeah most of
them most of them were named in the in
the 19th century and early 20th century
and do you think there was something
about once you start measuring them and
cataloging them it almost makes it worse
if people can sort of fixate on them and
think what phobias do I have and what
fears do I have and that kind of thing
yeah I think people want something's
given a name and a diagnosis people
recognize it in the themselves and
perhaps they also sometimes almost
nurture it in themselves and start to
there's a good example recently a phobia
called Trypophobia which is a fear and
aversion to clusters of hulls irregular
clusters of holes and this was only
identified in the early 2000s on the
internet because people started sharing
pictures and saying does this disgust
you do you hate this and so a whole
community of kind of whole haters
emerged and and realized yeah they sort
of shared this aversion and um one of
their number gave it a name and so that
was definitely something that by
identifying it people
um sort of started to feel it it can be
almost contagious
um or they or it was something just an
unnamed you know underlying fear that
was suddenly given uh given a diagnosis
and so yeah Trypophobia and it can be
triggered you know it sort of all sorts
of things like um the the bubbles of
soap suds or uh the the pitted back of
the Suriname toad
they often come across and that one
again can be traced to the disgust
reflex because
um that some scientists have speculated
that the these patterns these irregular
clusters of holes remind us of the
symptoms of infectious disease or of
mold or fungus things that might be
might be dangerous to us as a species so
there's a particular incident mentioned
in the book review of your your book
this week
um which mentions of sort of a Spate of
uncontrollable dancing in the Middle
Ages around the Rhine is that right
um I wondered how much he thought that
was sort of so it's got to be
interesting to that side of it was the
social contagion side yeah I wonder how
much do you think is sort of
is how much of these phobias are sort of
based on the world happening around them
is there a sort of a religious element
to it are they picked up with sort of
anxieties at the time or do you think
it's very much sort of localized and
it's about a cluster of people around
the same time it does certainly some of
the manias some of the manias in the
book are sort of individual manias like
compulsions to pull out one's hair for
example but others are collective manias
which do have this sort of contagious
group
um side to them and yeah the dancing
Mania known as coryamania was very
widespread it sort of took hold in a
village and then then spread and does
feel like uh and there's been all sorts
of theories about it from
um maybe maybe the people have been
poisoned by
um damaged crops poisoned crops but also
there are theories that it that came in
the wake of a great sort of flooding and
famine in the area and it was a kind of
outbreak of emotion sort of mass emotion
and that once and that people mimicked
you know they saw people sort of acting
out there Panic or anxiety and stuff to
emulate it and to join in and to feel
taken over by it so these sort of
compulsions it's really sort of
fascinating and
and they often are
um take place at times of great a very
rapid social change so when things
um change in a community there's
suddenly the community's open to The
Wider world or there's a a great deal of
suffering and and death then maybe a
Mania will sort of be a form a way of
expressing
um what was the anxiety that's felt or
the grief right and finally are there
any sort of cures for phobias do you
think that you've come across or or do
you think that people can successfully
be code of phobias that you've come
acrossed yes so there there are lots of
extremely effective treatments cognitive
behavioral therapy sometimes medication
talking therapy there there are lots of
exposure therapy is very
effectively where you um you encounter
your fear is that yes often in a
controlled and maybe grad agile way sort
of you know under supervision but
interestingly most people who suffer
from diagnosable phobias meaning phobias
that interfere with their normal lives
don't choose to treatment they instead
just avoid the thing they fear so um
phobias are rational at that sense
sometimes so yes but I want to come
across spiders for example yes exactly
just avoid despite so um yeah it's a
very
among the most treatable of the anxiety
disorders phobia and and yet the one
that people most often deal with
themselves
brilliant thank you very much Kate that
was fascinating thank you
that's it for this week once again thank
you to kind of called genuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes they'll provide you with the
expertise you need to help build your
wealth with confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectator's YouTube channel just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you